peu
ce soir dans passion d'auteur c'est
bernard henri lévy qui nous parle de
tocqueville cet écrivain historien qui
en 1831 parti aux états unis pour
étudier le système pénitentiaire et on
revient avec un livre politique capitale
de la démocratie en amérique
cent soixante treize ans plus tard
bernard henri lévy à la demande d'un
magazine américain atlantic monthly
repart sur les traces de tocqueville
il en revient avec american vertigo à la
fois un journal de voyage et un essai
philosophique sur le devenir de
l'amérique american vertigo
dans ce titre je trouve on entend
gronder et le mou vertige ce mot qui
hésite entre cette peur du vide et ce
sentiment d'exaltation extrêmes et je me
demande quel type de vertige
alexis de tocqueville peut bien
provoquer chez bernard henri lévy
peut-être cette passion de la liberté
la première chose c'est que tocqueville
elle m'a un peu sauvé la vie aux etats
unis
l'histoire que je raconte dans le livre
je me trouve un jour sur une autoroute
entre chicago et detroit
j'ai les routes américaines sont longues
les voyages sont interminables il
faisait je suis saisi d'une envie de
pisser soudaine et je décide de
m'arrêter sur le bas-côté comme j'aurais
fait sur une petite route de campagne
française sauf que aux états unis on ne
plaisante pas avec la flânerie sur les
autoroutes et à peine ai je commencé mon
affaire qu'un policier sorte de red lake
vient me arrive avec sa voiture un
grondement et un crissement de pneus est
au bord de me mettre les menottes de
m'emmener au poste de me faire les pires
ennuis j'essaie de lui expliquer que je
suis français ils sont fous complètement
que je suis écrivain il s'en fiche
encore davantage que j'ai écrit des
livres sur telle chose ou telle chose il
s'en fout mais leur éperdument et quand
je lui dis que je suis là sur les traces
de tocqueville aux états unis alors là
chapeau respect immédiate levée de la
contravention amitié total tocqueville
était son idole tocqueville c'est donc
ce philosophe français qui peut être
l'idole d'un high patrol policeman aux
états unis alors cela étant dit la
philosophie de devises
si je devais la résumer je dirais je
dirai les choses suivantes qu'est ce qui
aujourd'hui est valable qu'est ce qui
peut nous aider qu'est ce qui peut nous
nous permettre d'avancer de voir clair y
compris dans nos problèmes français dans
la philosophie de vie numéro 1 je dirais
une conception de la démocratie qui
n'est pas tellement française qui n'est
pas tellement jacobine qui ne ressemble
pas à nos grandes conceptions habituel
parce qu'elle nous dit que la démocratie
au fond c'est pas tellement une affaire
d'institutions ou que ce n'est pas
seulement une affaire d'institutions que
c'est une affaire de société civile
démocrate n'est pas seulement le nom
d'un système politique démocrate est le
nom d'une manière d'être de l'être
social démocrate c'est une certaine un
certain type de petites associations un
certain lien entre les citoyens les
habitudes les coutumes les mauresques
sommes dit parfois tall ville et comme
disaient les latins
deuxième leçon chose très importante que
nous dit tocqueville c'est que la marge
entre la démocratie et son contraire
entre la démocratie et la tyrannie
entre la démocratie et au fond le
totalitarisme
cette marge là n'est pas si grande qu'on
pourrait le croire ce que nous dit
tocqueville c'est que bien sûr il y a
une différence de nature entre la
démocratie et son contraire mais que
cette différence de nature elle est vite
comblé que cet écart il est vite franchi
troisième leçon de tocqueville très
important troisième leçon
notre fameux triptyque liberté égalité
fraternité le grand triptyque français
jacobin le grand triptyque
révolutionnaire révolution française
eh bien il est mis à mal par la pensée
tocqueville yens et notamment dans ses
deux premiers piliers liberté égalité
dans la rhétorique jacobine française
dans la rhétorique robespierristes
française cette l'idéologie française
comme il m'est arrivé de dire jadis elle
a deux piliers il ya le mot racisme et
ya l'europe espérait alors pour les
robespierristes liberté égalité ça
marche ensemble pour tocqueville et
c'est ça qui l'a de passionnant ça
marche pas forcément ensemble et
tocqueville c'est le philosophe
qui monte qui commence de montrer qu'ils
montrent d'ailleurs jusque pour
aujourd'hui qui montre que l'égalité
poussé à son terme
l'égalité des conditions poussé jeu dans
sa leçon extrême radicalité elle peut
instituer elle peut créer un type de
pouvoir régulier prévoyant et d'où une
sorte de nursing des citoyens qui peut à
l'arrivée leur coûter leur liberté il ya
aussi bien sûr une phase dont brut au
gaullisme et notamment de son enquête
sur l'amérique
tocqueville n'est pas non plus celui qui
a tout vu et tout compris il y à des
zones de fragilité dans son regard sur
la mairie qui à la question de la
pauvreté par exemple que tocqueville neu
neu ne vois pas où on voit où on voit
peu on voit mal il y à ce qu'il peut
dire des indiens ou des noirs qu'il le
voie purement et simplement pas évident
grands penseurs évidemment grand
philosophe qui ne faut pas non plus
angéliser idéalisé qui a aussi sa part
aveugle sa part opaque et sa part
tomber' mais merci
moi je trouve
[Musique]